اذا بالعوده الى ما اعلنته هيئه الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه بان هزه ارضيه بقوه 5.1
على مقياس ريختر ضربت ولايه هاتاي جنوب
البلاد كما افادت وكاله توسان السوريه
بوقوع هزه ارضيه شعر بها اهالي دمشق وحلب
واللاذقيه ومحافظات اخرى وربما نضيف بحسب
وسائل الاعلام محليه في لبنان ايضا مناطق
عده شاعره شعرت بهذه الهزه من عمان
الدكتور احمد ملعبي استاذ علم البيئه
والجيولوجيا في الجامعه الهاشميه ينضم
الينا دكتور الازياء هل هذه هزات اعتياديه
بعد زلزال مدمر
نعم رغمان
5-1 بالعشره وهذه على مقياس على الحد
الفاصل بين
الزلزال الخفيف والزلزال المتوسط يعني
زلزال خفيف يصنف
لكن متوقع متوقع الهزات الان وصلت 4000
هزات سداديه
وربما تستقر الصفيحه نحتاج من سته الى
ثمان شهور واحيانا عام فمثل هذه الاجزاء
متوقعه ولكن لا تكون بحجم الزلزال الرئيسي
الذي وصل سبعه وثمانيه بالعشره درجه اشرت
الى قوتها قوه هذه الهزه 5.1 على مقياس
ريختر هل لهذا دلالات دكتور
لان الطاقه لا زالت موجوده
وانصحها لا زالت في حاله ارتداد وليست
تصادم
هذا السبب هو السبب الرئيسي التموج هذه
الصفيحه او الصفيحه العربيه
مع الصفيحه
تموج الصفيحه العربيه امام الاناضليه تسبب
مثل هذه المشاكل والهزات الارتداديه
الوقت لو كانت هزه بوقت عادي ربما لا
تاثير كبير لها ولكن في ظل هذا الزلزال
والدمار الكبير الحاصل هل هناك مخاطر من
هكذا هزات ارتداديه باقتضاب شديد لو سمحت
المشكله هي الخوف من المباني التي تكسرت
بالزلزال الرئيسي ولم تنهدم مثل هذه
الاجزاء بقوه خمسه قد تؤدي الى هدمها مره
اخرى فلذلك هنالك مخاطر التفريق للسكان
حتى من اي مباني قريبه من هتان او من
كهرمان
الضروريه جدا شكرا الدكتور احمد ملاعبي
استاذ علم البيئه والجيولوجيا في الجامعه
الهاشميه في عمان